was there a life event i know you've
talked about bullying as a kid when you
were going through but was there a life
event that got you to say
i have to be the best at something
that's something it's it to say
i'm going to be the best at this game
i'm going to go all the way to the top
was there a certain life event was it
i'm doing it for my mom i'm doing it for
my dad you know some this kid said this
and i watched a video the other day
that's going viral i don't know if you
have seen it or not this thing got like
a couple hundred million views this guy
who's a boxer he's fighting the former
bully from high school the bully from
high school comes into the ring who
knows how to fight but he's fighting the
kid he used to bully all the time but
the kid that he used to bully all the
time
is now a very good fighter so the bully
is still trying to bully him and this
guy's destroying him i'm going to give
you the video to play it here in a
minute it's a great video i'll find it
i'll show it to you but what was it for
you that said i have to be the best was
it something you were born with or did
an event in your life say i'm going to
show the world what i'm all about
it's hard question to ask um
i think when you care about something
and i'm i'm a very by nature competitive
person
and i cared about about
about martial art i i um i got really
inspired by royce grissom and i think
i'm gonna try to explain to you how i
got exp inspired by him so maybe you
would understand how your brain works
i um when i was a kid i was bullied of
course and uh you were bullied as a kid
yes i was i was batman in montreal
you're saying great yeah yeah southshore
yeah i was bullied i was at instead of
focusing on what the teacher was
explaining in front of the class i had
to
focus on how i'm going to get my books
from my locker reach the bus before the
kids wait for me the older kids they
they had a program at the school where i
was it's called in french
tejeo it said basically it's kids that
were older than us that used to redo
their grade because they they couldn't
pass yeah so they were like
three sometimes three
two three years older than us but at the
time when you're a kid when you're like
seven eight years old it's a big
difference of course you have someone
who's ten years old and you're eight
or eleven it's not like you're 25 and
28. no no 30 percent older than you yeah
yeah
exactly it's a huge difference so a lot
of issues with this kid and at that time
i was you know i was most of my friends
were a
geek and intellectual people
and i was eight years old yourself yeah
there were like kids that were more you
know like star wars and you know like i
like that stuff you know like automatic
and i was like that too but i was very
good in sport you know always been like
in my uh among my friend i was the one
that was pretty maybe the most athletic
guy in my friend so
and therefore i was
very often in situation that i uh
when there was
they had we had trouble with these older
kids i was the one stepping in to you
know try to you know to fix it but
unfortunately it didn't go my way very
often so on in the street i have a
losing record
if i if i look
in my in my childhood
but i start martial art as a
self-defense
and uh so if i if i then the
self-defense become quickly a passion
because
things were not
going well for me at home and they were
not going well at school either the only
place where i felt i was valuable i was
i had value and i was doing well it was
in the dojo the place where i was
training that was the only place that
it was very rewarding for me to be there
so it became a passion
part of your identity almost yes and and
i learned that the discipline there
because i grew up with a lot of anger a
lot of you know negativity
and and at that time i i
i felt a little bit oppressed you know i
didn't realize how lucky i was to be
born in a country like canada with all
the opportunity i felt like i would i
i didn't see the world the same way i
was seeing it
and if i fast forward later
one of my my karate teacher died and
when i saw rose gracie
i saw the first ufc i was a teenager i
saw a guy that did not look very
intimidating
but he was fighting these other guys
that were much much better than him
they look like bullied to me
and he looked like the victim yeah
alright so when i saw him winning the
first tournament in the ufc
i saw him do
things that i was never able to do at
the time
like revenge taking a river the revenge
defending himself against the bully so i
believe that's why i got
very inspired by what he did and right
away i was like man this guy is like my
hero i want to become like him i want to
be him because i was not able to do that
when i was young i want to be i want to
do like what he did so i wanted to
follow his path and right away i told my
friend at the time said that's what i
want to do i was already a black belt in
karate by what age uh i was around 13
years old and this happened when i was
15 years old so i told my friends and i
want to become ufc champion they all
start laughing but by 13 being a black
belt because i did karate as a kid and i
remember they gave i was like a brown
belt by like age 12. but was i really a
brown belt exactly that's my question
like were you really a black belt by
each 13 like a legit badass or was it
kind of the belt is only there to tie up
your gear it doesn't
the system of belt it's it's a it's a
it's a reward system business thing yeah
and and
you know what in reality the belt is
supposed to be white yeah but
over the years because you trained so
hard over the years it's becomes dirty
dirty dirty it becomes black you don't
have to change the belt like a white
yellow
orange green what a concept you want it
to become natural yes
that's how it should be but now they
sell these belt because they're much
more now even they put stripe in it to
make another in between yeah it's a
business thing so it was a brown belt
with black stripes
but i was 12 years old any any 18 year
old would have kicked the [ __ ] out of me
a hundred percent but but what i mean is
it's not because you're
you're an higher ranked belt that you're
more of a badass if that just mean that
you might have more knowledge
than the lower uh rank belt it doesn't
mean you're necessarily a better fighter
but when you're a kid you know what i
mean there's a a factor of strength
maturity you know there's a lot of thing
that plays out so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you